für mein empfinden mit große gewalttätig
können was heißt das denn deutschland
gemeinsam machen es aber keinen satz
dieses geduzt macht mich
dass ich meine kraft dem wohle des
deutschen volkes widmen das ist nicht
die stimme von urlaub schriftlichkeit
gegen jedermann ein von den von helmut
schmidt deutschland aus der krise führte
stieg er für dich in die politik ein mit
euren noch als arbeitsrechtler kämpfte
er an deiner seite
dieses gewusel
in den wahlwerbespots macht nicht
arbeits und sozialminister sicherte sein
kurzarbeitergeld zu süßen richtiges
bewerbungsvideo erster bürgermeister von
hamburg sorgte er für wohnungsbau wie
kein zweiter olaf scholz seit jeher für
und scholz der absolute boss
erzählt nicht so wie selber wieso der
mann einlässt erzählen so macht man das
ich glaube dass der auf den mit dem
schmidt anfängt
dass sich daran dass der ja auch mal
finanzminister waage und dass sie beide
hamburger sind und natürlich das mit
charisma für zwei hat und das ist in dem
fall habe ich ganz angebracht als
vizekanzler und finanzminister kämpft er
mit wumms gegen korona haben sie gerade
gesagt hat mit booms gegen korona
gekämpft
ok manches erreicht
und jetzt geht es darum wie mehr zu
schaffen holz immer allein was natürlich
vor allem immer hoch heisst die spd in
ihrer ganzen zerstrittenheit kommt noch
nicht ins bett um das anzupacken kämpfe
ich für 12 euro mindestlohn damit zehn
millionen arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer mehr für die 400.000 ein
bisschen sehr leise trete risch für so
ein wahlwerbespot
wünscht sich so ein bisschen mehr druck
in der stimme also man kann nicht im
gleichen werbespot sagen mit booms gegen
korona gekämpft und dann aber auch
treten so samt für die neue wohnung
jedes jahr damit dass wohnung wieder
bezahlbar wird stabileren klimaschutz
dafür bitte ich um ihre stimme auf eine
inszenierungs ebene ist dieser spot
dessen
tonya zuversicht
vertrauen im urlaub scholz und zu
verbreiten bin zutiefst melancholisch in
dem eben dieser einsamen mann durch mehr
oder weniger leere räume
schreitet
kann aber ganz gut zeigen dass das eben
funktioniert das ist ganz alles ganz
professionell gemacht wobei ich immer
nicht weiß wohin leute eigentlich der
läuft ja und es sieht so aus als sie
läuft der vom mittagessen zum büro oder
umgekehrt und darum möchte ich unserem
land als kanzler die
deutschlands zukunft lag das an aus
respekt für dich respekt für dich dafür
ist das ist dass die
spd deswegen werde ich geputzt mit
kompetenz für deutschland spd soziale
politik für dich auch deswegen dass du
natürlich sonst geht das ja nicht hin
sonst müsste es ja sps heißen soziale
politik für sie die sonst müsst das pfs
heißen aber ist ja auch egal